yo what up everybody Anna Mack here for
anime Opera welcome to another episode
of rent cafe the craziest podcast on the
Anna tube we have been in an arc of
tournaments lately and today is no
exception we're gonna be debating the
best character in boku no hero my hero
academia etc we have 16 contenders we
have five panelists here and we're gonna
be voting debating and voting at each
person each character with three votes
wins as usual and joining me today we
have knox taco and all day anime the
regular dudes what's up guys great how
are you one of the times easier to
manage but great I'm like what's up guys
great how are you freaking Canadians we
also have we also have sold mock up back
yo yo yo are you all done welcome back
man
and back by very popular demand teching
101 what's up bro
I'm doing good thanks for having me back
I didn't even know there was that much
of a strong fan following here but I
appreciate it yeah yeah we owe in the
previous stream you were on in the
comments there's a lot of people like
you gotta have checking on more often
tucking tucking teching yeah I was one
of those so really good glad that we
lied to have you back on thank you for
your time and I'm boku no hero guy
yourself you made a whole video on
freakin oh yah ma
so yeah and then and today I'm going
through the whole class of 1a today I
did Jiro's video it was 28 minutes long
so by the way I'm pretty sure I'm top
comment on your how yeah my video might
be
probably yeah also guys just so you know
before everyone in the chat welcome of
course just so you know before you start
complaining we can only do 16 people and
we decided to do people who won't spoil
the manga and also people who we know
you know a decent amount of both so not
like a random class 1b student and stuff
like that so yes people already in the
chat where's Tohru noxus pissed at best
genus tis not there I'm so
okay okay so guys let's get this
straight I am really happy that I had
zero contribution in picking the 16
characters are making the list because I
don't see toka Yami I don't see best
genus who's easily the greatest
character of all time ya know if we
[ __ ] up on toko Yami
how did I think my lady don't melt lady
come on join us no giant ass already
puts him and puts her above back going
mom I mean honestly cast of my her
Akademi you could probably just do two
tournaments at ease you know yeah
there's a it's a huge cast it's like you
had and we could if people like this we
could do like a best girl you know best
dude in whatever right so there's plenty
of options but like I said we had to
settle on 16 it was 16 that I think are
the most popular and so no uyama I'm
sorry guys
oh yeah ma ho never stop concerned about
the lack otoko Yami love but I can
that's my favorite character but I can
bear it for this will be alright yeah
Wow by the way I see Josh Duff Nina Chad
shout out to him we met him in real life
at anime North that was great damn
Aussie we he trolled me so hard he's
like Joe are you Briggs the fortnight's
tree merrily on otaku thank you for $2
to say for my dose of rants and made
cafes yes the main aspect of this cafe
has not been developed yet but you know
dude why do you just tell me I have a
maid outfit I could wreck it award it
alright next time I'm just gonna have
that I ever what a bunch of weird [ __ ]
my prop trunk but that's not one of them
yeah me neither yet yes yes the bracket
guys you can link it in its linked in
the description we'll take you to the
Twitter page where it's posted and yeah
Briggs made up the bracket and he
decided to really go hard by pinning a
bunch of popular characters against each
other in the first
because he didn't want everyone to sweep
through the first round like in previous
times so it's yeah [ __ ] crazy
well I like it I propose remember guys
no Todoroki for Takayama
right edge go no no totally bro I just
re-watched I'm working on a video and I
just re-watched the distain fight and
Todoroki is [ __ ] absolute badass
again stain so Briggs why don't you
watch some boku no hero and shut your
mouth
I mean post intense I was a little bit
rocky decline but tournament are can
sustain are so thorough he's amazing I
completely disagree
I think pre-stain and posting [ __ ] he
sucks
like through the tournament I hate him
so much so stain is like the dividing
point of the series right here well
after the comedian he started to have
his own ambition he wasn't didn't have
daddy issues he started to try to get
stronger and not just rely on his Opie
Corral well okay look he doesn't have
daddy issues in the same way but it's
not like he's like okay dad let's go
fishin now we're best friends like
they're working they're getting better
at it but they're still like this this
brackets can need another one of those
Todoroki speech by the way I knew it I
knew it we have Tosca in the chat saying
I personally like the manga bubble guy
yes I knew it someone was gonna mention
the manga bubble guy from class one be
that we know nothing about I knew it oh
I thought you're talking about the
washing machine hero from the last
chapter like no yeah okay guys want to
get into this lovely bracket or what
yeah yeah remember guys never stop
twinkling yes yeah this is my new motto
I want to sleep in best genus and Ollie
i'ma fight to the death I want to see
that Jesus is like many more deadly sins
okay
of the of my here academia alright so
the bracket again link in the
description to the Twitter if you want
to see the full bracket first stop we
have short o Todoroki vs. Kirishima
Todoroki terror okay
Kirishima
he's in for the boner guy whether we
kiddush him a very popular guy he's
doing a guy who can you know stay hard
get hard instantly he's a family man
he's worked on getting harder and yeah
he works to improve himself constantly
no yeah it's true and if you play my
personal favorite part about Kirishima
is that he's constantly chasing back ago
and back ego hates it really liked him
he he sees Barca go is like oh man
you're pretty cool goes be best friends
and he's just like get the hell away
from me I don't want you around but he
kind of secretly Baca goes like you know
because when the whole thing with the oh
I don't want to get that's kind of manga
material I don't wanna get into that but
yeah and that's when the doujins
happened
definitely you know a cool character
he's striving he's inspired by red Riot
right he's uh he wants to be a real man
a man's man he wants to improve and get
better and become a strong hero
definitely a cool character
Todoroki total badass struggles with you
know family issues and overcomes and
it's just just I love them I love
Todoroki [ __ ] what anyone says Briggs
definitely my vote like Kirishima my
vote has to go to Shoto Shoto
a bit wrong with total he was pretty
young strong before the tournament
yeah no no by me if he's saying like now
he's not relying on that overpowered
quirk I would say you're wrong again
because now he's even more overpowered
well I mean yes the fire and ice I mean
he'll if she did something to improve
post tournament I see ice like
pre-tournament he's like [ __ ] this like
I really don't care about getting
stronger I'm already overpowered the way
it is I was born this way I don't even
need to use my other half you know he
was trained brutally as a kid okay no
the way he was first introduced when it
was like the two heroes against the two
like students that were role-playing as
villains and he froze the entire
building that was extremely badass
because we knew nothing about him and
vodka go started pissing himself and was
loves a clue
exactly that was an amazing introduction
for his character not only that but in
the tournament he was also overpowered
until his fight against Deku where he
actually had a basically even fight for
a little bit now punched in the stomach
hard
yeah he should have been obliterated
there but aside so sure who gets donated
to large to say not
Todoroki well you can keep your money
because Todoroki wins but well you can
keep your money sorry you can't it's
already money you could keep it yeah
there's no actual refunds on YouTube but
you could do a refund within the first
few minutes or something I don't know if
you can I heard good wins the first
round sorry condition my respect
Todoroki the [ __ ] he's gonna get even
sadder and sadder every round as he D
yeah I'm kind of middle of the road with
Todoroki I really don't have a super
high opinion of them I'm just like isn't
every manga there has to be a character
that's just inherently I like a genius
right out of the gate and you think
that's gonna be Baku go but then
Todoroki shows I'm like okay there he is
that's the character I was waiting for
yeah I think I never liked those it is
to be fine I don't have it hatred of em
or anything I mean there's always gonna
be a kid that's gonna be more you know
genius more you know adept at using
their course than the others I guess it
makes sense but yeah well it's also
funny I'm looking at the bracket right
now and the pictures Briggs picked for
every character it's like in a normal
pose except Todoroki looks like you
sitting I literally all get a cheesy
version of him cry crying speaking of
which Deku is in the next round throwing
out the main character real quick this
is a hard life I could not it's easy for
me okay that's it I'm choosing that cook
nice
I also guys I know some of you might get
upset but I don't like Baku go I think
he's too
pissy all the time and moody for no good
reason he's a teenager that's the reason
no less mature Vegeta so for that his
less mature than Vegeta so that would
make sense yes so for that reason
deku for sure for me aka 4 years before
a 33rd of you guys vote for deku uh-huh
I would like to say something about baka
go sure yeah defend defend bak we'll go
please because I win a lot of people
like him a lot of people oh ok I will
give you one thing
Lord explosion murder is d bad okay it's
not a never stop twinkling but it's up
there mm no it is the beep at Lord
explosion murder is the best the best
superhero names at least have four words
in them yeah well King is supposed to
work remember only is three and never
ever stop I don't actually know hey
you're gonna say and you stop twinkling
canyons like I I never stop twinkling
yeah but we have a funny ama in the chat
just religiously chanting Baku goat Baku
goat they're nice they're very they're
very like they're both they're about to
break alright one guys throwing money at
you to tell you Todoroki sucks but
anyway I would like to defend vodka go
first I dislike Baku go as a person
right but as a character is a
fascinating character deku I mean I like
him whatever but as a character
especially as a protagonist he's rather
bland I mean I do like how they're
developing him and whatever but as far
as a more interesting character back to
go definitely wins he's the guy who
always thought the world of himself he
always thought the most of himself he
always knew that he was gonna be to
everything and things started standing
in his way so as time progresses he's
starting to realize his own flaws and
he's starting to realize that you can't
think too highly of yourself or you
won't realize where you mess up he's a
character that's constantly developing
in the story despite me thinking he's a
major dick and he's definitely not my
favorite character I have to say a
hundred percent he is one of the best
created and developed characters on this
list in the entire series even though
even though I like that could
I vote back we go I'm gonna leave this
one all up the teching because I'm
blowing my god I gotta go with Barca go
dude a lot of stuff that he just said
and I don't want to spoil a lot because
this is going into manga territory
involving Baku go after the provisional
license exam I think you know what I'm
talking about here but I really don't
view him as just like a dickish
character he does act angry all the time
but he's a teenager I can I can relate
to that because I had a friend growing
up that was very short-tempered was very
just quick to anger all the time but he
was a nice guy just you just don't piss
him off and I view that baka go kind of
in the same light so that might be just
a little bit more of my real life than
leaking into this character but um yeah
a lot of the stuff that he said I really
just I agree with all that so I gotta go
with Barca go I don't view him as just a
straight-up just you know he's he's
angry all the time and that's his
character is nothing more to it there's
more to it but well I'm not a little
[ __ ] like Sasuke I understand what you
guys are yes he's not the emo ish
character he's got average but at least
he doesn't have the eyeliner my problem
with buck was sometimes he's just so
entitled like he bullies deku just
because i have a better quirk so how
dare you get in my way kind of thing I
think what it comes down to with that is
just when he was a kid and for so long
he was ahead of deku and ahead of
everyone
ahead of everyone but deku especially
because that could didn't have a court
and then finally when he did get one
Baca go was probably thinking like oh
yeah you have a court but I'm still
better but then slowly throughout the
series it kind of builds to a boiling
point when the to confront and it's like
at that moment that's when the track
when Rizzo occurs well but there's a
boiling point where it shatters and Baca
go has to start realizing that you know
deku could surpass him and he has to
kind of come to terms with that and kind
of change his outlook a little bit and
we're gonna see where that goes in the
story but yeah I think that that at
least yeah at the beginning he what he
did feel entitled but that's slowly
beginning to ship away as the series
progresses and another thing the
entitlement is in noir is a more normal
human emotion than let's say Dec ooze
let's smile forever
that's much oh my I mean I'll give it to
you and plus once again they're
teenagers they're not gonna be thinking
as rationally as you know an adult would
be in this situation so I kind of get
him I really do I get back I go yeah
yeah like with Bongo he definitely
develops but I also think that we have
to remember the deck wood develops
throughout the story because he begins
as crying for every little thing now he
not only every other day in the manga
I'd say but I would argue out argue that
back ego does not develop because at the
end of day all you get is one little two
panels three panels yeah of him seeming
like he's developing but then straight
after that he's straight back to the
same old [ __ ] good night so I would
disagree with you on that point because
you see throughout the story he feels
bad for other people too like for
example before he fights
Todoroki there's this whole scene where
he says like don't think about your
parents don't think about your issues
okay I got a better one for you monkeys
when he's up against that Kuya and that
who takes the hit to punch through the
ceiling yeah to help win that little
test they're doing well oh yeah yeah
yeah we see a brief moment in in Bukka
gazaís where he looks like he's feeling
sorry for Deku tell me he let up on Deku
throughout the rest of that series at
any point I not sure what you're getting
at to be honest in that brief moment
that was the beginning that was the
beginning of batter goes adventure that
was really when his character started
developing until that point he was the
major dick edge Lord dude and at that
point he lost to Deku he saw Todoroki do
something that he couldn't even imagine
doing and he was crushed and he said I'm
never losing again um honestly I I don't
like to I could go as a person as I've
mentioned but I do think he's a much
more interesting character than Deckard
okay so me and Sol Deku the rest of you
guys Baku gold oh yeah no no no let's
not go that far I really don't have like
good reasoning I like the
it's such a close decision I think I
like Baku go better because I feel like
there's a lot of funny moments
surrounding them and I'm gonna vote him
against Todoroki so Lord to the next
round
all right cool your one hundred million
percent smash the nine hundred million
percent slight plot armored smash no
very slight I call that the power of
friendship one hundred trillion percent
we're really talking about serious plot
oh yeah we're talking about about oil
money all right Todd next up next
bracket is you know ah she doe versus
sue you frog girl whoa what meaneth
course again she kids she could spit
acid not spit but she could secrete acid
yeah yeah you mean new mutant quirks
right mutant types yeah yeah she know
was the same as buck ago he he sweats or
anything yeah she just does acid it's
actually a cork very similar to
[Laughter]
definitely an emitter yeah the acid
quirk I get I feel like her appearance
might just be like inherited because you
know like the meeting quirks to be like
inherited without a power before we
continue let's just understand that her
hero name is pinky and flower girls hero
name is frothy two sick names I mean if
I was in danger I would also call out
for pinky and Freud her first idea oh
she knows for an idea for alien queen
and I'm like that's [ __ ] him badass
[ __ ] yeah maybe something a little
different pinky I'm like oh my god that
sucks let her keep alien queen I don't
know I think that if she would work with
a gnome ooh they would become pinky in
the brain for a long time I thought
she'd oh I didn't really think much of
her I thought that it was horikoshi like
okay I don't really have a lot of
character for her so let's just make her
look interesting rather than have a
personality that's interesting I mean
over the course of the series you get to
know a little bit more about her but I
feel like she really hasn't had her time
to shine yet I'm gonna go with frothy
yeah do we get
five votes for frappe here with boku no
hero there are fans like every character
has fans like I've seen people say yeah
yeah I've seen people say Mina is best
girl if you don't agree you are mentally
ill do you is overrated I just saw in
the chat I please leave who gets a lot
of love she does she got my time she
gets a lot of love and spotlight time
and I like I don't know to me these two
I like them both but I I don't you know
I don't have a preference to be honest
here's a question for you horikoshi was
originally going to make su you a male
do you think he would have been just as
popular if it was a guy with a frog no
he would have been overshadowed by
Moneta oh yeah yeah maybe I mean four
people got big well from what I saw at
first when people started like cutting a
pair off with decking just because of
the right but the anime but I mean I
thought she got made from the DAO jeans
I mean she's alright she's alright
I mean she's we've drawn a character
chat chat let me know guys spam whoever
you prefer sue you or Mina in the chat
but I don't I don't think like do it
like a million times but say who you
prefer not that it really matters cuz
frappys gonna win I mean there we go
oh we got one meter in there to me by
the way who said who who are you guys
voting for you are proppy Robby I'll
vote for frothy okay so frothy has three
votes aye I guess I'll go for Mina so
it's three two right yeah they're not
getting far anyway hey there are some
people saying Mina in the chat I get you
guys so it's three two frothy and soo
you also getting a lot of votes respect
but to you makes it to the next round
congratulations frog girl now next up we
have to
Cheers ribbit Eraserhead very popular
character everyone prized how many
people thought that his quirk should
have been in the top ten all peak works
list which I don't consider I feel like
his quirk is very useful for a pro euro
you can turn on people's quirks but I
wouldn't say it's old P cuz he don't hey
Anna Mac if you had his quirk would be
pretty damn useless yeah because there's
no other people with quirks right but
but yeah so eraser had very complicated
quirky likes to sleep and like randomly
sleep in a sleeping bag middle of class
respect and we have all might the
pinnacle of heroism but then also a more
complex character due to the his other
persona right his weaknesses yes small
white there's the small mite and the
tall mite within him so guys take it
away take all right so I would like to
start because honestly looking at this
list this was the hardest one for me at
like hands-down this this is the most
difficult one and while I like all might
to the point that he even made a whole
video on why I like all might I still
think I'm voting Eraserhead on this one
cuz he's a far more complex interesting
character and he's not your average like
all might while he has his Superman
phases and he also has his anorexic
Superman phases we're all worried about
everything like he's not a
middle-of-the-road guy he's either like
biting his nails and scared to death or
he's smiling while beating the crap out
of brain chickens or whatever those
nomas are so I would have to say III
vote a narcoleptic Kakashi on this one
narcoleptic Kakashi um I personally like
eyes about you you can tell eyes it was
been through some [ __ ] right like yeah
yeah he's been through some stuff in
life so definitely respect that I
respect what he did during the hide out
during the forest training camp arc like
has done a lot of stuff but to me you
know all might he is the symbol of peace
he is the guy he is the inspiration for
so many people even stain was inspired
to become a hero because of all might so
my vote is for all might yeah I think
it's awesome like the think that like
he's probably in pain or like suffering
a little bit when he's fighting someone
because of his injury or whatever or
like kind of like you it's time to run
yell type of thing
meanwhile he still keeps on this like
smile for the public and it is so
awesome and badass so even though I love
Aizawa if I relate more to him like I
got a vote for all my breaker kind of
thing I I think I'm gonna go with a
Aizawa on this one I view him a lot like
and this has been shown earlier on in
the story it's kind of a parallel we're
all mites always out amongst the people
and and he's well known and established
as the symbol of peace whereas I saw was
a hero but in his own way he does it
like under cover of darkness and he
doesn't like the public eye and
everything like that so I like that so
he's basically like kind of like a ninja
that can erase people's powers I like
that and I just feel like I was more
developed than all my I mean if this was
taking place in the my hero academia
world we would all vote for all my cuz
he'd be like oh my god he's like our
superhero Jesus but that's not the
situation's I I got to go with I though
I liked him more just as more favorable
character fair enough sold again what
yet no all is the break to tiebreaker
yes but it's hard though cuz I mean III
like both for different reasons and it
like a totally different story like
within the story I shower does more like
yes he's a constant yeah
no no he does more three times a he's
doing you know he's they're teaching the
kids or you know arranging their classes
for them to be taught
he's they're protecting the kids
constantly you know I mean no look at
the the current arc like during that
whole attack where was all night in the
tub on screen time or well well we have
to because hasn't it now me net I would
win how how are you gonna get to know
the characters that out screen
well you can get to look I like some
characters like Dec who has the most
screen time and he's already out of this
competition
yeah while you think I can meme so can I
ask you a question why is it that they
got cement guy to be the mediator during
the tournament so that like Dec who's
flying at Todoroki and he makes a cement
wall from - smash into and they didn't
get Eraserhead to be able to be the guy
mediating it and erased their quirk that
was right after he got his face pounded
in by a gnome ooh yeah like orbital wall
fracture yeah he was in the yeah yeah
yeah both zones were still bandaged and
everything yeah he's still recovering
but yeah I don't know yeah but oh my and
he was in the booth with all Mike that
should have been his name oh yeah I'm
not know I guess enough to go with all
mine I'm just going to call my sensei
but all might make the next round in
which he will be destroyed by to you but
let's let's go back to the bracket we
have me meta best boy versus zero oh yes
girl girl who doesn't much because she
isn't bad developed but actually zero
like all these other girls has a lot of
fans I know Jojo talks too much think
she's absolutely nuts mmm what you think
you know his best girl
zero is best characters your best girls
especially like a Yama and all and all
genes whatever his name is but anyway
when we met up me Netta's best boy all
the heroes should just have all at the
beginning of their names you know have
you saw they all do yeah sounds like a
drink doing it
yeah they do 4p like some kind of coffee
yeah yeah yeah Sutton you eat
dear son heaven all might I now
picturing all might in like a coca-cola
commercial or something he would fit
perfectly nobody can't cuz then stain
won't hate him
oh yeah you everyone everyone would
leave stains but all I could kick the
[ __ ] out of stain so it doesn't matter
oh okay so me as the guy who made a
video called how sticky our minute des
koala that's how I got exposed to you to
actually yeah it was either that or the
Titan shifter video one of the two but I
watch them around the same time
okay yeah so that video is approaching
like 50 K which is crazy I like I didn't
think I mean it the video would but a
cool guys thank you I have to go with
Mina Turkey is hilarious he is a more
complex character than we give him
credit for and okay good I totally admit
that this might be biased cuz I
literally just did a video about zero
like two hours ago so I did a lot of
research with her today so I got jizz
like you know what she's a pretty cool
character especially in this last dark
not the last dark in the anime but you
know so I gotta go with zero I think she
has a lot of qualities that are
overlooked you know I think she's low
low low low key best girl but still best
girl she is he's literally a rock star
and her parents are like wrong she is
she her parents were rock stars and her
quirk is one of the examples of like her
pant her mom had the exact same court
that she did and so there's like a
direct like transference of work so we
don't need to see that all too often
right so I I'm a little upset that you
put best boy against best girl here make
it really hard for me but I'm still
gonna vote Jiro and I like her for a
multitude of reasons and then why what
zero man did you just say chief what the
[ __ ] Knox what I was like all like I was
already going to look at the chat I'm
like not just with me like Nasia he
feels violated yeah sorry family wait
wait I elated my sticky balls ball might
got nothing on zero is it two against
one right now is it already over yeah
it's two four zero versus all time you
all speech on zero but I guess I'll let
you go well it's gonna be - - because me
nada is my favorite character in the
entire series like
oh my god
Thank You Briggs also yes chat knocks
Taku top 10 anime portrayals right here
ok well this this makes it kind of easy
for me I got the choice between the
potential electric lover or the guy who
gets to ride Momo so I have to go women
are sorry yeah man that was closer than
I thought I was like this bracket should
I mean to be honest with you if I didn't
just make all this research about Jiro I
probably would have voted for Mineta
Mineta is like the little pervert inside
of all of us you know we understand for
me um me Netta would have beaten any of
the other girls on this list but Giro's
best girl so I'm not just gonna wear in
this list
I'm not bro we have girls coming up yah
mo mo just turn it out there yeah we
have what our cover says all that Briggs
you said something about rigging the
bracket next to all three of the girls
at the top right so he's gonna make it
to like the quarterfinals hopefully we
have here so Ericka vs. Momo
Baraka is I believe that she was
designed to psychologically be as cute
as possible like if you look at her
proportions like her eyes and like her
face and stuff I feel like she's like
one of those minions like she was
genetically designed to be kawaii to the
max he's got seats that are always yeah
yeah so I think that's kind of kind of
cheating I don't like her motivation for
being a hero though so all right a
second that's the kind of thing yeah
that's the kind of thing stain would
like kill her for ya oh yeah definitely
yeah and like I think it's cute I think
her and deco are a good couple but I
gotta go with my girl yah mo mo yeah all
right so I think this is also 5 votes
I'm voting for your raka oh you know to
pronounce her name what this is like dr.
this is like the first like female like
side character that like or like main
love interest I've actually liked I said
main love interest I always [ __ ] hate
them and I actually loved her so I
thought I vote for her I don't know I am
blown away right now
like my thinking what series I never
liked the male like the like the main
love interest or the main love interest
or they just totally the person that you
you think they're gonna pair off with
that mangie what about Kenichi yes my
wife so you're not a fan of Hinata mmm I
mean in the beginning it was Sakura and
I [ __ ] hated her for a majority of
the series like Hinata came out of
[ __ ] nowhere in the pain like I
didn't know where you mean like she
didn't own an episode one that she had a
crush there early on we knew the Hinata
like Naruto but Naruto liked Sakura
Naruto liked soccer from majority of the
series
I feel like Hinata like for I always
wanted he nodded to win it cuz I [ __ ]
hated Sakura but you thought Sakura was
gonna be the one I thought Sakura soccer
will be the one majority of Naruto at
least the first 120 episodes all the
girls all the girls got their first
choice except you know who had to go for
science
yeah ty and Sasuke she got the leftovers
yes she got diet sauce oh yes I was
definitely I don't know anyways he had
Knox you thought that this was an
obvious choice but there no or chucko
has a lot of fans man I know I know but
as far as youtubers I didn't realize
anyone was on Ochoco side aside from
explanation point I like her but Momo
this is an evil bracket you put Momo
right next to raka if we look at my I
love most quirk way more than the
gravity court ya know I'm with you but
character wise I can't believe Jiro laws
never mind you take this from here
taking why what am i doing I already
voted
alright
Stane versus sugar aki get out of the
girls what who won so I don't techie
were from mobile first yeah
would have been it would have been free
to would have been free to them your
Momo Momo all right so you're in Seoul
would have been for America what a plan
but that was an interesting mix of going
from from best girls to Best Villain
boys we've got stain versus she got
hockey okay so five votes for stain yeah
five votes for staying I yeah I choose
overhaul no understand stain was not in
this series for very long but we find
out so much about him and his backstory
and his motivation it's it's unique in
how he handled it like he had this he
was Billy like day of flying heroes like
they were his like Jesus or Christ
figures or something where it was just
like they have to act in this way and if
they do not then they are fallen from
grace and it's my responsibility to kill
them all and it's very powerful of what
like this society watch in that stain
became into existence so we only get to
see him for like one art but he left a
very lasting impression in both the
fandom and in the actual story because
of all the extra villains coming over to
you know shigaraki side shaker aki could
be ruined right now it wasn't for stains
influence yeah one Costain being locked
up cuz if you stain one locked up
shigaraki wouldn't have the following
he's got well sadly got captured
whatever it was a trigger of events I
wouldn't say I like staying because of
the way he deified heroes I I would like
staying because of his flaws his
philosophic outlook on how heroes should
be for example it mentioned in the anime
God knows why it worked this way but it
was mentioned in the anime that the
cities that after he killed her you know
wiped out five heroes crime went down by
a large portion it mentioned that and
honestly I don't know why I don't know
why his actions would do that but it
almost had like a fanos
type vibe you know no it's cuz he kills
villains as well
he don't just kill heroes he he he kills
whoever he defines as evil yeah yeah so
kill villains as well
Shigure a key that he'd kill him as I
told him face-first too bad he didn't
yeah well I've personally I'm just
working on video on stain right now I
actually saw everything teching said I
completely agree with I think staying
for the little amount of time that he
has yet screen time he is such a
overwhelming presence and such an
influence on both the world and on the
fans so I'm definitely going with stain
however I do agree that shigaraki
develops a lot and he is underrated I
feel like a lot of people I go screw
shigaraki he's just this edgy dude I
feel like he is overshadowed a lot by
his on Suraj like there's a lot more
people that you focus on instead of him
you know
no I like sugar Aki I think you're the
great quark and you don't develop a lot
as well but stains impact on the series
and just like like like knuck said like
it I guess his philosophy whatever is
that like I I fell in love with stain
yeah Wow five votes for stain yeah yeah
his first guy and I did you guys know he
appears in vigilante and it's really
weird kinda yeah I didn't like that very
much he became a little aunty before he
became the hero killer yes yes he did
but I just I don't I don't know I guess
it makes sense for the character but his
his vigilante costume I wasn't a fan of
it was I think it was a little bit too
sleek and now he goes into this like all
rough and rags and blood everywhere and
then he was like I didn't like maybe
there's a story there I don't know yeah
yeah there's a story look what you did
to his face oh that's right yeah I think
it's stained if stain would have gone by
the name AIDS man it would have been way
kind of like backed off at that point
okay well next up we have dobby versus
toga to newer villains and by the way
Dobby is very popular like I've noticed
people saying like comments and stuff to
my videos people are like
doggy's my favorite villain and stuff
like I feel like a lot of people just
think he looks cool and other people
other people think he's probably short
on the rookies half-brother like me so I
yeah I think Dobby has a lot of fans man
Bobby on the haters and I personally
bought Dobby over yonder a [ __ ]
bloodsucker thing just personally
because while I don't know his motives
and I don't know his past he definitely
has motives and he definitely has it
passed while blood sucker bimbo does not
she's just a fun character to watch so I
would vote that be also even though I
don't really know him that well yeah I
kind of agree with that um when I was
talking about the episodes he was in I
was just like he uses blue fire
therefore he's automatically like one of
the coolest characters ever I don't know
um but I like that I like his design
it's just it's very striking very
different the patchwork the fire I mean
it's so cool I gotta go with Dobby yep
chat by the way Dobby or toga yonder
white fool vs. cool guy
Yann Dre lolis Halima she's not a lolly
I love the enemy I wouldn't classify her
as a lolly now no she's like a senior
high school age at least and she's not
even like shaped like a lot that makes
me laugh because that makes me think
that she just goes to high school and
acts that way like can I suck your blood
on math today well it is Japan okay that
is sure who by the way deck who donates
$1.99 to say Dobby is lit figuratively
and literally good ones true good solid
why do I think you guys realize that
endeavor can turn his flames blue as
well because he's probably followed the
father of Dobby why you know what I we
know I just want to say about that I
don't wanna get too off the rails
obviously is that there's people that
think Peter his half brother just only
because he uses fire as well that's just
ridiculous I mean there's a bunch of
people that could use fire but I'm sure
there's other stuff yeah that Becky's
dad that his dad can use fire yet could
we never find out we never see him
that's weird don't worry he's gonna end
up either being the main hero
confirmed
to be fair and ever wanted a son that
had both like the wife and his quark so
man could be like oh you only use fire
get that up get the hell out of my house
or like not even disown you like he like
became an or it could be the first kite
kid he had and he could only use fire
and maybe I don't know yeah yeah there's
no there's definitely no like solid
evidence all about it up I feel like
narrative Lee as someone who also writes
I feel like it would be a cool twist so
I I would be a cool twist I actually I
subscribe to that theory pretty much I
think it makes a lot of sense and it
would answer why he's doing what he's
doing and yeah cuz endeavour is such an
example of like a corrupt hero like
someone who has a body myth of what
stained hates yeah like a public persona
is horrible like personal life like and
I personally love endeavour as a
character though just gonna put that out
there I think he's a sick character
because he his purpose in the story is
really really interesting because like
for example Stane wants him dead but the
truth of the matter is in that hosu City
thing he saved tons of lives
he killed the Nomos he protected the
heroes he protected the civilians truth
of the matter is he's a positive
influence as far as the world structure
however because of his narrow-minded
you know ideal of growth
he's kind of a bit of a dick so he does
have a does have a pretty flaming
mustache though this is anybody voting
for toga
I vote dad because he looks cool and I
don't have especially like her in the
later like manga stuff yeah yeah I feel
like Dobby just has the potential to be
like a major villain like to overshadow
even like shigaraki eventually in some
ways and go out on his own so I can see
what getting his own arc yeah vote for
Dobby Dobby other haters second round
well vote for Koga because I don't know
as cool as Dobby is he never got to
realize any potential I guess that makes
you hated yeah
all right so we're gonna be moves on
next and now we're going to the next
round where we have Todoroki vs. Baku go
[Music]
you all like struggle and sink
Hiroki wins guys okay breaks you vote
it's for one let me say la least I'll
say I'm voting bloc ago as nothing
overpowered done right in my I've never
been a fan of overpowered characters
unless they like I had some type of a
comedic value to them like with Bach ago
or Eskin or or Saitama for example I
feel like I think Bach was a very
interesting character yeah it's yours be
honored I'm cringing a little that you
you put Eskin or one punch man yeah why
I could go in the same category I lost
my head no no no Bach ago would be both
of those characters to get this bit
debunked Wow like I feel like he's
overpowered and he used to me he's bland
and I don't like him but that's just my
opinion and he sucks a little [ __ ] are
you I am overpowered no I will say like
I said box will definitely develops I
think like first he irks me the wrong
way but then he develops later however
Todoroki I really like him he has a
complex difficult personal life that
motivates him first he's conflicted
between his two sides but then he kind
of like gets to you know for the sake of
being a better hero he overcomes that he
he's so badass during the tournament art
during the stained arc he's cute with
Momo so yeah I gotta go with my boy
Todoroki every time the guys on screen I
love it screw this of course Todoroki
wins yes
Todoroki easy okay yeah so we won we won
let's not make
diction's but I think I know who's gonna
win Briggs yeah how will you react I
already had a feel like you is gonna win
to be honest but I'm not gonna wait
stains gonna win oh man don't predict
what predict because we've had some
surprises no don't don't count Minetta
out just yeah again everyone Todoroki
has just entered the semies Oh next
round we have to you versus all night
all right so if I saw I would have one
last round out of said this is really
easy and I saw one beets crappie however
since it's all might all might still
really easily beats Friday sick
character and Robbie is prop is great on
cute and and doesn't care if she
destroys you with a single roast still
my votes easily going to all my complex
that's dude that's uh that's basically
my views on it frothy is I mean a lot of
the votes come from like she's cute she
has a neat design and everything like
that but that only gets you so far I
gotta go with all my Sam here I think I
think who needs to develop more as a
character before we can you know compare
to the legend himself all might ask
annoy someone talking about Lords we go
did I hear okay so all might yeah who's
into the semi-finals where he will be
facing against Shoto
Todoroki we're gonna do the right
bracket next looks yeah oh yeah you know
out of the bracket we have mean--it ah
versus mole mole this is gonna be a
full-contact battle I mean it just rips
off his clothes and just hey let's do
this just wearing that legendary night
oh forget about the booze for once let's
go I won't buy that stick your little
bubble [ __ ] versus mo mo
well I'm voting free monadic he's my
favorite character and he like for me
like you've literally I'm not even lying
he's my favorite character in the series
no it's it's fine for me to have value
he adds makes me enjoy my academia so
much more so me Netta it is every
popular manga does need to have a
perverted character just it just has a
lot of University oh yeah for me also
like Momo his best girl in terms of like
the students but I have to go with my
boy mimetic he's just the most
entertaining one of the most
entertaining characters in there so it
just in terms of like entertainment I'll
vote for me at that but Momo has better
quirk Momo is best girl and yeah alright
so well since I don't want a third guy
voting for me yet before I get my piece
out I'm voting for Momo easily hands
down because while I like the moments
with Minetta the lasting impression
comes from Momo and also aside from
being fanservice incarnate where she has
to take her clothes off to use her quirk
this is so smart it isn't this movie at
the best ever it's just like the most
amazing thing I've ever read is it is
that great Knox because you didn't seem
to like that and kill a kill which was
done brilliantly yeah sarcastic I didn't
pick it up and you just insulted killa
kill which is stupid though I like it
with both I like it I think it's a cool
funny thing I like when service is done
for a reason and not just blinking okay
so once we're on the fanservice page
I do like Momo's because Momo's is for
comedic effect you're trying to find how
brilliant killa kill is with the
symbolism of nudity and dude I'm not
buying that for two seconds we could do
the killa kill debate another time I
vote for Momo cuz it's funny that her
court happens to be that she has to take
her shirt off to pull her off every time
depends what she's it does when she's in
like a normal outfit yeah she's making a
cannon out of herself she has to take
off her shirt or whatever but if it's
like her normal outfit which is already
I'm in the hero outfit which is already
really revealing she doesn't have to do
it every time but
but the reason she can use her quirk the
whole series is based off female
characters that have to take their
clothes off to use their quirks
you know midnight take your clothes off
so we're talking hell are we talking my
hero my hero academia we have we have
Momo that takes her shirt off to use it
work better
we have no zero
I like geo for different reason but Momo
don't know Moe before I change my mind
yeah I say Momo's oh yes my you know
what this time neck and neck thing here
but that King bro yeah moving on me
that's a loss sorry fan are you
what I'm what up challenge Knox talk
with me mean credentials now right now
take you on I'm a big Mimar guy and I
love me love me Mom you have to love me
my friend my friend you do not
understand the traumatic effect of
oversaturated memes eunetta is an
oversaturated living meme and therefore
he automatically loses credibility in
the eyes of a true original connoisseur
Mimar yes
not like not happy have you read up on
meme theory because I have I took two
semesters at that college of ticked so
don't come back
look I'm not look I know they teach that
memeing for dummies thing over there but
I've read it Sir Isaac Newton's third
fourth flawed physics which are okay
I'll meet Momo Momo Momo makes it
assembles even though I preferred me in
a tough but what can you do [ __ ] guys
Briggs you're getting nothing you wanted
anyway anyway we have stain against
little stain a Dobby stain by the way
I'm going for Spain because while Dobby
is cool staying is more too
and also stain is the inspiration for
dobby so I gotta go first a about goes
thing cuz I was gonna go with Togo
anyway so I go stain to stain cuz I like
I said I barely remember dobby
I thought you looked cool that's what I
mean he's relatively new to be there but
yeah yeah so basically stays just
crushing at five old yeah my predictions
are based off me it would have been
Mineta
stain all might and baku go in like the
next round
yeah two out of four two metaphors yeah
before we are in the semi-finals guys we
have Todoroki versus all might and momo
vs pain first let's do Todoroki vs all
night a excellent young startup
developed brilliant character students
Todoroki versus the legend himself the
inspiration almighty almighty i mean as
as it's not a fight and it's just like
for the characters that we see yeah I'll
have to go with Todoroki because I like
way he's growing
whereas oh my is pretty much done now
for us especially us manga readers
anyway he's done we're not gonna get in
that new out of him so yeah I'll go with
totally the legacy he left behind him
and eyes you're correct but I there my
character development wise there could
be stuff but yeah yeah I understand
where you're coming from
um I've wrote Todoroki how long coming
Briggs who do you vote for I already
said all night but like I think that was
coming in certain when I said last time
about all my bits like being super
badass and me I don't look like insert
the time that I ripped on Todoroki last
three rounds we already have I think
what why why who are you voting for why
am i next ball because I just wanna sort
of see what you say because of course
I'm voting for Sparky
team Shoto here
sorry Briggs well I love all my bomb
like I like that short oh he's
developing as we are and like I said our
yeah he is my favorite of the you know
male student guys more than Bach will go
in Dec why relate to Todoroki so yeah
he's my god that's a big reason why I
voted for him because I'm like he still
has so much more that we haven't seen
yet yesterday and that's the thing he's
developing a lot better than buck ago
when they have that time when they have
that time like you know when they have
to like the exam time yeah fear anger it
is yeah I mean like you can see the
realization and understanding of where
they're going wrong like hit them
differently
yeah me and I like it Todoroki handles
that and understands it and then wants
to improve wears you know angry guy just
stays angry which for me back again
shows no development in his character
you know yeah but he's funnier yeah so
Briggs must be furious right again if
you don't know what the bracket is it is
Lincoln is in description but basically
we have Todoroki now in the finals you
see that face that you use their brakes
for Turkey does the baseball winner and
even go to the bathroom occasionally the
other semi we have llamo versus stain
really good developed villain or boobs
this is gonna be tough mm-hm
the art of the boob is strong in this
one however I would have to vote for
stain because it has to be another five
yeah I got a vote for stain I'm working
on video on a my and I'd the more I like
again he's not perfect
I don't want to overhype him I feel like
he has a lot of flaws and his like
reasoning and stuff but is definitely
like a great villain in my opinion yeah
my favorite so far no hero even though
some people are saying in the manga they
have some people they like more I
definitely like stain the most just
because his presence bro like his he's
so he has such conviction that people
are like oh this guy's
[ __ ] yeah millions are allowed to have
crazy reasoning that's not obviously
like perfectly logical that's why
they're a villain they're not not like
endeavor if you look at endeavor like he
has so much of a better quark than stain
and yet endeavor is like frozen why just
like stains presents no stains an
amazing character oh my god I love the
guy I made a ton of videos talking about
him even videos I went off topic to
compare to stain because it was so good
I do that every day like every video I
make is like goes off on a tangent at
some point it's like so dr. Vega Punk
has new inventions let's talk stain I'm
gonna do a video uh talking about stain
and comparing him to Garo from one punch
man hmm just cuz they're both they go
like hero hunter hero killers no no I'm
here yeah however stay here's the more
developed character obviously but we all
see like I'm voting for stain if I don't
Annalee I voted yet I'm voting for
staying why do we flav this in the chat
sis can we put gang auric on the list
like I knew it I knew be able to do what
hat hey can we put that one guy from
whoever wants gang ork on the list but
let's talk about who is that denim is
strong with this one
so everyone votes for stain yes yeah I
love Alstyne is so powerful even like
without his quirk
that's what blows my mind stains quirk
is useless I mean if he would have put
toxins on his knives he would have been
even more dangerous than needing to cut
the guy then like the knife they say his
quirk is essentially nothing but it's
creepy as hell this is true hence the
name AIDS man by the way the official
stats his speed is six out of five yeah
he sees wikis ridiculously fast
yeah Salkin okay so Spain has just
crushed it so far got five and oh all
three and I mean Sofia Soler okey and
this is my nightmare because these are
hard I like the most
these are GU hi there are a lot of
favorites if you think about it
he also kind of crushed you one-for-one
every single time for 1vs5 nothing this
is true and also thank you very much
Briggs for not putting stained versus
Todoroki in the first round yeah no I I
tried to make the match like the match
up makes sense but also difficult yeah
no this was great this was really great
does he know it's not great Todoroki
winning if anything this really does
just prove house how impactful the
character stain was and Todoroki is one
of the main cast of the series stain
only appeared in one arc he's here in
the final round and it wasn't even like
one of those you know 45 episode arced
it was three episodes yeah three
episodes and he's here ya know I my vote
since no one else has the guts and gall
to speak up except for Briggs who votes
for stain I also vote for stain hands
down I love Todoroki as a character he
has nothing on stain this isn't even a
hard decision for me yeah you're not
you're not alone I I vote stain - you're
not alone oh thank you because I don't
have like I don't have too old that I am
so afraid just to give him something
yeah he deserves I think he deserves at
least one vote hey doesn't deserve to
sweep in the final round but let's not
be a [ __ ] and vote what say you
man if they're so different he is my
favorite villain told her okie is a
student he is my favorite student like
okay now assuming that it was two - what
would you say man oh we're a lot of time
guys I'll vote for Todoroki yeah I would
vote for Todoroki and I'll have to say
that the next the next bracket should be
sexiest female in something like you
have to you have to be specific though
because it's very hard when you have it
as just like a kind of generic title
like breast character because then we're
tossing up and weighing up what what
makes them best yeah
and we're talking about our personal
preferences so Spain wins 3 -
congratulations - stained my favorite
villain character making a video on him
respect love Todoroki to love Momo lots
of great characters yes so in terms of
the girl I don't want to do sexiest
because what like how do you judge that
it's just preference we have to do
things who is best girl in terms of
personality yeah well I think that's not
good anymore even [ __ ] be in there
fine however you define best girl yeah
no no I'm saying like because
personality wise you don't really know
much of midnight mount lady the snake
hair girl you know these are those ones
that were with them you know the guy
well you know in the delay a bubble
girls [ __ ] so many hot but I think we
shouldn't just do my here academia I say
we do like a full on waifu wars female
character is having multiple theater
there are issues here because like when
it's gonna be REM vs megaman what are
you gonna do about by the way yeah this
was really fun take everyone yeah for
joining us leave a like if you enjoy
ryan cafe and don't forget that we're
here either on this channel or an ox
tacos channel every Thursday 5 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time like so New York
time if you wanna hang out and check us
out we do different topics every week
and yeah really fun really fun guys
we'll talk about some future topics
later and let you guys know we had the
honour of being joined today by teching
101 thank you sir hi yeah welcome
his link is in the description as is
everyone else's we also had the honor of
Knox taku joining us oh what an honor an
unexpected honor yeah it's like I've
never been here before
Thank You Strait having me you're lucky
that I've even giving you an outro I
appreciate the honor of having an outro
on the prestigious rant cafe and clearly
you need to learn the art of the meme I
will tutor you after so no we will have
some kind of me mores the two of
so I see a video in that some kind of I
was gonna be interesting I was gonna ask
is this always on your channel anime
uproar is this like do you alternate
back between the two or how's that no we
usually alternate between the two of us
I mean like right now my here I could
amy is bigger on his channel so makes
sense yeah right so deadly sins on my
channel could finally have one on mine
yeah I'm down yeah seven deadly sins
like bracket or whatever I like I know
people are like [ __ ] brackets but I
love they're so they're so fun
ridiculously fun I think that'd be the
only time it could be on my channel if
it's seven deadly sins shout at unknown
otaku in the chat who says that we have
to have Knox taco more often yes yes ah
it's true it's true oh we also had
Briggs from all the anime joining us yo
I love Ron cafe I love doing brackets
I've haven't had I literally I look
forward to it so much I have so much fun
doing these debates even if Todoroki
went way more way further that he should
have and yeah twitch be beastly Briggs
that's what I shout out now oh yeah I
liked I liked your YouTube but he also
has the Twitter and also we had soul
maka joining us a guy who actually reads
all the mangas in the world who knows
this understand every manga before it
gets published it has to go through soul
yeah
every black blur everything but no soul
is actually he helps me a lot he advises
me in terms of like boku no hero he
gives me heads up when something really
big happens in a chapter and I haven't
read it yet so yeah definitely huge shot
of him he also has a YouTube channel
like a description I don't know if he's
posting I don't think it's been posting
lately yeah mainly AMD's have been
posting at the moment okay yeah I'd have
to say other oh no I'm not really fond
of brackets and such because I always
feel like someone's left out you know
and yeah
rest in peace all jeans yeah and same
like especially like the last one what
was it the best villain one like that
was like like the bracket itself is
triggered now cuz
or only though why was Digimon in there
like crawler not marry him like
maro him because he was more popular
with the most popular villains knocks
knock me knocks what it wanted to do
metrosexual vampire mom you creeped me
out when I was a kid that as you should
a giant monster for me cab yeah that was
freaky [ __ ] it sounded like him from
[ __ ] Powerpuff Girls yeah weird
reverb they did with his voice it was
freaky as [ __ ] nightmares about him no I
still think I wanted the greatest anime
villains that we totally forgot last
week was Mojo Jojo
oh gosh why don't we just put freakin
Wiley coyote from Roadrunner I think
that's a good idea yeah yeah man any
bracket you can think of we we have to
do anime tournament Ark with only
mother's basement anime only like the
not Japanese anime like scooby Doo an
avatar the house but yeah so this was
awesome guys thank you again for joining
me thanks everyone in the chat you guys
have been great to be able to check us
out by the way if you are at this Court
person you want to join the enemy
discord we have chats there so you can
link in the description to that as well
and yeah I think that's everything so I
think I can unless anyone has anything
else to say before we go no yoga match
sucks that's it it's been Parker's Oh to
the guy in the cat named loyal loyal
theorists of matpat do not watch my
latest video I'm pretty sure he's
another one of those torturing knocks
Taku with me holy God what's wrong with
those guys I know there's so many
accounts now and none of them are me
well yeah by the way this YouTube video
Lee's not cringy out roll until next
time see us space cowboys bang you did
the thing